- When you say that passion
is the ingredient that
most matters in success,
I agree but here's
how I think about it.
Without passion nobody,
if Tony Hawk wasn't passionate
about skateboarding,
if I wasn't passionate about
becoming one of the great
entrepreneurs of a generation,
If LeBron wasn't
passionate about basketball,
they wouldn't have put in,
I wouldn't have put in
the hours, the work.
When it all makes no sense,
when it's 10:30 at night tonight
and I've got to go to
one more meeting
but I got to wake up at 5:30
and if I didn't have the passion
for the game, I wouldn't to it.
I would cancel it.
I wouldn't have booked
it in the first place.
And so, it becomes the gateway
drug religion that allows you to
do the tactical things.
I have a vision to where
we're going in the future.
I come up with stuff every day
that very few people are
thinking about and then
in parallel, this is one of the
biggest reasons I still
have a personal brand,
I use Instagram and Snapchat
and Facebook and Twitter
every single day.
I'm a practitioner.
I get my hands dirty.
I'm the architect
and the mason.